[Music]
hey everyone it's your favorite niche
internet micro celebrity rough criminal
here hard to believe it's been more than
a year since i started doing this it's
been such a fun wild ride and i'm really
grateful for all the support tomorrow is
the premiere of my long-awaited illmatic
review which i promise will be equal
parts disappointing and extremely on
brand i wanted to let you all know that
i'm planning to free myself from my
self-imposed upload schedule that means
two things the first thing is fewer and
less regular 10 second reviews the
second thing is more longer videos i
have some ideas for long videos moving
forward that i think will be fun and
freeing up my plate a bit is going to
give me the space i need to make that
happen and of course i'll pop back in
with some 10 second reviews here and
there i really hope you all stick around
to see what i have in store and to tell
me that i fell off because ooh i need
that i had someone tell me i fell off
who i needed thank you all for the past
year and for making this stupid hobby of
mine into something i don't know kind of
real i appreciate that and i'm really
excited to see where things can go from
here hey i got to interview danny brown
who knows what else is possible
[Music]